thanks Jen Grandmaster Patrick wolf who
I've known for many years I think the
first time we played Patrick you beat me
when Harvard played against CC and why
in the Pan Am Games is that a lot of
water under the bridge since our college
days the you're in finance now the
markets have been up and down and crazy
and so has the chest here in st. Louis
what has been your impression of these
amazing games well I'm really excited by
the games today especially the aronian
in the Nakamura games it's it's good
fighting chest it's a lot of fun to see
you know these guys are really going
after each other that the top player is
like they don't play boring they really
go after it it's I think it's a lot of
fun now back in the day we had elite
tournaments but did you ever expect or
suspect that we'd have chest live
streaming online big studios it's
confessional booths quite a bit as
change hasn't i love the confessional
booth I know I never did although I did
write the complete idiot's guide to
chess almost 20 years ago and I
confidently asserted in 1997 that within
five years you'd be able to follow a
chess tournament on your on your mobile
phone and I was off by about five or ten
years but I never imagined how amazing
it would end up being and it just keeps
going it's great you are a good friend
of Vishwanath on anons you were a second
to him yeah when he was fine for the
World Championship title yep back in the
90s you had breakfast with him this
morning where were his periods when he
was he was chatting with him oh I think
he's fine I mean obviously he's
disappointed by the first couple rounds
in the tournament but fishies played a
lot of chest and seen a lot of chess and
knows how to bounce back and we were
just talking about how things have been
going and more sort of personal you know
over the years than anything else we did
spend some time talking about how
computers have really changed chess and
it's you know for an old fogey like me
who hasn't played really seriously for
20 years it's just amazing to see how
the players both use computers as a tool
and have really adapted their play so
you get people like Wesley so or Hikaru
Nakamura you know who really sort of
seemed to be shaped by the computer and
Anand was saying how you that the range
of moves that the top
players can just sort of think about
these days is much wider he things
because the computer has really sort of
taught us how much more is possible when
you're looking at these young players
who are you most impressed by well I'm
impressed by all of them but I mean I
you've got to be really excited about
the Americans right Nakamura Kara wanna
and so I mean it's it's incredible that
we have three of the top ten players in
the world in the United States you know
sort of almost by stealth over the last
five years incredible and I mean of
course magnus carlsen is i mean to be
exciting yeah i think the secret's out
but it's pretty amazing to see just how
good he's been with this incredibly
strong generation I think the strongest
of all time just still have someone who
sort of dominant by that many you know
by that many points and it's amazing
well you made a prediction in 97 about
five years from now I'm going to put you
on the spot again what do you predict
for chest in the next five years okay my
prediction for whatever it's worth is
that in some way the internet is going
to really change the way we follow chess
I think so far what we've done is we've
taken the way that we're used to
following chess and put it on the
internet and the combination of the
internet and the fact that computers are
so good and only going to get better and
better and better there's going to be
some way to put that together in a
different way I don't know what that's
going to look like but I think I think
that will be the next big frontier that
and eventually cyborgs will be the best
chess players well we appreciate your
insights thank you very much for joining
us I'll thanks for having that keep
enjoying these games absolutely
Grandmaster Patrick wolf two-time former
champ of the United States sharing his
insights with us back to you guys Thank
You side works cry when they lose again
yes they do oh the idea that go they do
everybody cries Maurice I just had a
question for Patrick before we let him
escape before today before we came on
the show Patrick and I were talking
about how do you get chest more popular
how do you bring it he had a heel we
playing off the confessional booth what
Patrick made a suggestion of how you
glimpse into them
end of a grandmaster and remembering the
monrovia idea Patrick go ahead take it
what we were talking about earlier just
sort of brainstorming right but I kind
of like this idea that you figure out a
way where the players actually are able
to analyze just by themselves during the
game and we get to see the analysis and
compare it in real time to what the
computer is telling us so we actually
you know you ever see like poker we're
like you sort of know what the hand is
and then you should put you don't know
what the card is going to be well here
the tension would be you see what moves
people are looking at like you know like
the Aronian game or just what what's
Wesley looking at right now and you
could see whether he's thinking of a
brilliant defense or losing line it
because the computer will tell you you
bring up Wesley there was some there was
a lot of controversy in the US
Championship when Wesley was defaulted
in the game for taking notes and the
argument is that if you start having
players allowed to put down some kind of
movement notes to themselves that that
would assist them in their thinking
process do you buy that no I think
actually the crime there was that he was
using analog sort of old-school just to
work just private notes for himself it
should have been digital in full flower
for all of us to see that week so we can
see whether he's right or wrong I mean I
think like I think the game the game
part of what we love about chess is its
constancy right I mean it you know it is
essentially the same game it's been I
don't know sort of 100 200 years and it
goes back over a thousand years but the
world is changing quickly now right and
we can take this game we love and may be
adapted a little bit because we have
this amazing medium the Internet as yes
or was one yes when I were talking yes
we was saying you know that the TV's
never been the muse for chest but the
Internet can be I think they're probably
some interesting things we can do there
but in the meantime I'm just going to
enjoy the chest it's pretty exciting day
today I'm really glad I came absolutely
well thank you so much for those
insights fascinating stuff we'll see how
it goes in the next five years of
Patrick is behind the times or ahead at
the time wheels
see thanks so much for joining us my
pleasure